how long have you guys actually known
did you know making the first movie that
you were building towards the multiverse
like how long have you guys known what
this movie was really going to be
at least a couple years yeah for a while
yeah yeah but
they're not fun
i didn't even know what the first movie
was about when i was making the first
movie
accurate you know we were so in the dark
right
but now we really know and we're part of
the team the creative team and you know
they trust our opinions and they ask us
questions and stuff so we've been
sitting on this secret for a very long
time
long longer than i would have heard
about it i was like
okay cool but like that's probably not
not going to happen
for sure yeah so later they'll pitch
something else because that didn't work
out yeah
later we're now finally that was like
for a long time there was a craven movie
that was going to be the third movie
because
things weren't working out and all sorts
of different stuff and john pitched me
this craven movie which actually was
really cool
i i don't want to talk about it in case
that movie ends up happening down the
line but it was fun
you